sie ist auf der sonnenseite des lebens
geboren monats in 2001 mit der 20
triebes sie zum studium nach paris
jahre später als dolmetscherin der
migrationsbehörde hörte sie die meister
funden geschichten ihrer landsleute die
vor der armut ihrer heimat geflohen war
nachdem ich neun jahre in paris lebte
realisierte ich zum ersten mal dass
meine landsleute aus indien und
bangladesch
nach europa kamen in einer furchtbar
schlechten psychischen verfassung waren
sie haben gebettelt und sich erniedrigt
um ihre situation dramatischer
darzustellen obwohl sie furchtbar
kritischer ich fand es abstoss sie alle
hatten ihren stolz und ihre
selbstachtung vergessen
in ihrem roman r schlag die armen hält
die hauptfigur dolmetscherin wie die
autorin die lügen irgendwann nicht mehr
aus in einer kurzschlussreaktion greift
sie plötzlich einen jungen migranten an
ohne hinzuschauen habe ich nach der
flasche gegriffen und der gewicht
gespürt habe auf diesem kopf gezielt und
zugeschlagen
der roman rückt indische und bengalische
asylsuchende in den fokus die wollen
nach europa weil sie arm sind selten aus
politischen gründen
sie hoffen hier auf ein besseres leben
ein trugschluss
meinst du arm bist in bangladesch dann
wirst du keine rockefeller in frankreich
du bleibst an
es ist einfach eine andere art von armut
in oman werden nicht nur die
asylsuchenden kritisiert auch die
behaarten das gesamte europäische
asylsystem stellte monats in frage
wir jagen die leute die über die grenze
kommen aber was ist mit denen die sie
hier locken
diese illegal arbeiten lassen die diese
sklaven system aufgebaut haben
ich finde dass das politische system in
frankreich die leute zum lügen zwingt
also kaufen sie falsche pässe falsche
identitäten falsche geschichten
es gibt autoren die solche geschichten
für sie finden das problem ist dass das
politische asylsystem ach so das absurd
wurde
man erwartet sozusagen eine besondere
geschichte von den asylanten unterwegs
in europa wird asyl nur aus politischen
gründen gewährt indien aber ist von
armut und einer klimakatastrophe bedroht
ein dilemma
simona senat meint würde man diese
flüchtlinge für einen begrenzten
zeitraum aufnehmen müssten sie nicht
mehr lügen könnten ihre würde waren und
irgendwann zurück in die heimat
doch eher buch ist auch eine provokation
die schriftstellerin sagt darin dinge
über ihre landsleute die von
rechtspopulisten missbraucht werden
könnten hatte die tochter eines linken
politiker vor niemals angst in der
literatur in der kunst solltest du diese
moralischen begrenzungen ignoriert diese
selbstzensur tötet als ich muss ehrlich
sein
aufpassen dass ich in der literatur
nicht nett noch böse nicht schön nicht
hässlich bin darum geht es nicht
ich muss die wahrheit suchen wie ein
starker teil muss ich den gedanken in
der wirklichkeit folgen
simona sänger nicht mit ihrem buch ein
tabu in der aktuellen flüchtlings
gebracht
sie stellt das system an den pranger
aber sie kritisiert auch die
asylsuchenden ein wütendes und
poetisches buch
das den blick erweitert